here the set I'm going to define would
you find the universal set and this is
just that particular example sees people
well defining Universal set has all of
the integers from 1 to 30 okay we'll be
counting numbers by the way just as I am
just a side note if you ever define a
set like this right and you want to
follow up a team you need to have at
least three numbers in here to start off
your panel right one number obviously
it's not enough to establish a patent
but two numbers isn't enough either
can anyone suggest why like if I had
said just that why would that not be
enough yeah good that's right if I just
said one two you don't know whether I'm
adding or where the Ryan multiplied
right so there's ambiguity there right
so to get away from ambiguity three's
kind of a global number okay
all right so there's our Universal set
I'm going to find set a to be the even
numbers that belong in here or if you
like the multiples of two set B I'd line
is defined as the multiples of three so
we're thinking about this is our
playground one today okay multiples of
two multiples of three you're gonna
start off your diagram here's the
universal set there and we've got a and
B in this some overlap between them okay
so easy example we start with the first
one one where is it going is one a
multiple of two no is it a multiple of
three no but it is in the universal set
so I'm just going to stick one down here
okay to where it is to belong
to belongs in a there's a belonging in
between nope is not also multiple three
so it has to be in there three obvious
is going to be here you can go from
there okay I'd like you to fill in all
those numbers I'll give you a couple
minutes so we've got our multiples of
two over here and multiples of three
over here our our double ups and then
our our ones who don't belong okay
now let's have a look once you've done
this deep serve any patents right
the most obvious pattern that jumps out
to me is if you have a look at a
intersection B right there's a very easy
way to define a intersection B without
saying any section b it has its own
quality about what is it
they're the multiples of six right
multiples of six okay so when you when
you take into sections or unions that
kinda thing you get new properties
sometimes now have a look at the other
ones
for instance this area over here how
would you define that how would we write
that in set notation just this area this
area you can say it a couple of
different ways you could say well that
joint one name right but I want baby so
I would probably say I start with me and
then I want to get rid of a but I think
that's probably the easiest most of sick
way to say like I said many ways to skin
a cat okay well what do you notice about
these particular numbers over there and
obviously they're multiples of three
because they are part of set B but what
kinds of multiples over three other of
course because what you think matter
look you've got this is this is one
times three right that's seven and then
3 and then 5 and the
nine one three five seven well of course
they have to be the odd multiples of
three because all the even ones are in
here right anyway you can keep going and
here's my point is diagram it's a it's a
helpful way to see things but it's not
the only way I want you to think back to
when we're doing a remember we're doing
the four color theorem okay and we had a
look at maps okay
now you might want to draw this up
quickly for you if I gave you you know
three countries like suppose that's like
Italy or something out of it okay so if
I gain your map like this okay I very
very briefly mentioned the idea at the
end of a lesson that form a of from a
topology point of view right which is
thinking about these spaces and how they
relate to each other how they fit
together right all this jagged business
I don't really care about it right I
could say this is kind of equivalency
well I could round this all up I can I
can throw it like this I think no except
let me have a look at this one it
borders these two okay so let's call
this a B C a B C so any borders B&C sure
be ordered borders aunty it works okay
these two from a topological point of
view they're equivalent and I could go
one more you know who says it has to be
round does that surround the control
like this that'd be still the same right
you got the same concepts there now you
can see with our Venn diagrams right why
are they circles why is this a rectangle
around the edges any particular reason
really um then the guy who designed this
he was very keen on symmetry right and
so that's why he's like circles the most
symmetrical shape ever right Infinite's
you know reflectional rotational
symmetry so that's why he was very keen
on circles right
but they don't have to be okay sir
rub off all of your countries okay well
no not rub off on Rulon off and then
underneath them let's think about this
what would be another way to represent
the same number of sets are there any
better ways now I was given example this
is literally an infinite number okay but
I can tell this is kind of equal to if I
didn't if I wasn't constrained to make
these circles okay I could say well
around the edges I could make one kind
of like a um like an all-boy me sort of
shape another one which is kind of a
degree but this is still from a
topological interview this is still sane
right I've still got Universal set only
a only B and an intersection but then I
can make this simpler I can make this
simpler look at all this space over here
what is it doing and the answer is on
our diagram well it's not really doing
anything in particular right it's not
doing anything that this space this
region is not also doing so I can kind
of get rid of it I can say this is I'm
gonna spank somebody else basically this
is equal to ducky imagine if I took
these and I sort of melded them to the
side okay so here is here's one of the
circles which I squeeze that I squashed
let's regather so he said he's a and
he's me morphed a little bit he's a he's
be all still good now at least in this
case I've taken this tall one I've moved
it over there and I push it up against
the side but I'm still okay I call this
big right now where would he go with fun
move it down to the bottom it would look
something like this wouldn't it there's
a okay now hold on a second
does this look the same as this it's
time to look quite different isn't it
but it's still the same it retains all
the same info
which is the most important one I'll
tell you how I do it in this diagram
right let's go let's think about maps
and go through how many separate
distinct regions are they I know there
are two sets but there are there are 4 1
2 3 4 region and you can name them you
can name them you can call this one well
this is kind of there's nothing in it
right you can call this one a and not V
you can call this one B and not a
and in this one the middle of course is
intersection ok over here I still have
the same 1 2 3 4 regions and to make
sure you haven't lost them you can have
a look at this one that's the empty one
right over here you've got a and not B
up here you've got B and not a and then
you've got your intersection down here
okay so let's formalize this let's get
rid of all about curviness right and
let's just draw this like what it looks
like this is a table right I'm going to
draw it I'll do right here like this
okay like sir right now the reason why
I've got these extra bits off the top is
so that I can label what these actually
mean okay so if I call this one up here
let's call this one a and not a okay so
even numbers not even them call this one
B and not B okay so now where would the
numbers fit for instance these numbers
out here in the universal set right
which don't belong inside where do they
go they're gonna be yeah good it's gonna
be over here right the arm you guys
don't belong sorry okay so I'm gonna put
all of these guys here 1 5 7 11 13 you
get the idea all belong
here okay in knotting up it
conversely I can take the opposite that
the intersection a and B right and
that's going to be these multiples or
six we talked about right six 12 18 24
okay and you can fill in from there okay
and I'd like you to do that now as
you're doing it you can label it you
know you got a Venn diagram down here
this guy appears guy who formalized as I
saw artist this connection I can do this
differently a guy named Carol so we call
these cattle diagrams now he wasn't just
any Carol just think there are not that
many famous Carol's that you might be
aware of how many cows can you think of
that you learn about yeah Lewis Carroll
Lewis Carroll off what what is Lewis
Carroll famous what did he write he
wrote Alice in Wonderland right he's the
thing who's Carol was not just an author
he was a mathematician now maybe you
didn't know that but Walt Disney knew
that which is why when he did not Alice
in Wonderland but Donald in math magic
plan which you watched a couple weeks
ago right you might have even noticed
those of you who were keenly aware
there's a scene where they're starting
to talk about all these different games
I think it's after the music it looks
through billiards he looks to check his
the solutions chess and it's suddenly if
you were paying attention Donald he gets
a new outfit change he's dressed up as
Alice in Wonderland okay and in fact if
you go back and read how someone that
it's full of maths especially in its
sequel through the looking-glass so you
can go and have a look at that a Lewis
Carroll
so we've got these two ways of
representing sets and how they relate to
each other and as you will discover in
the next couple lessons they each have
their own particular benefits